house cameras my name's PewDiePie I'm
just gonna get right to it I have some
important news for you bros YouTube is
broken to see what I did there so clever
the same thing happened last year it
happened a couple times already my
videos aren't sending out properly to
the sub boxes this is kind of a
reoccurring problem with YouTube but it
seems to be happening to me a lot since
I have so many subscribers so I've been
getting a ton of complaints from eros
saying why is he not uploading videos
where's the [ __ ] video is he sitting
on his ass again picking up baby not
exactly like that but still I am
uploading videos I'm uploading one a day
I don't know if you've seen it or not
but it's there you can still watch it at
youtube.com slash beauty pie but it
might not show up in your sub box icon
tag to YouTube I hope they're gonna fix
it as soon as possible I'm sure they're
trying I just wanted to let you boys
know so you know what's up I do actually
put some effort in my videos so it feels
kind of pointless for me to upload to as
I usually do if not everyone's gonna see
them anyway but hopefully we can get
back to the regular schedule as soon as
these get fixed so that's I'd say I
don't think I want to talk about since
says you're here are you doing by the
way
you have great hair though basically
what I want to talk about is I don't
know why but anyone who's become big or
whatever uh gets the stamp of like oh
he's is big now he doesn't care anymore
oh he's big now he doesn't put in the
effort anymore he started like all these
things I see them all the time and it's
very frustrating because I do care and I
do put a lot effort and I'm getting a
lot of people saying for example Oh pity
pie just says he's the most subscribed
person now since I have so many
subscribers I say those things
sarcastically because it's so dumb I say
it as a joke for example if I say I'm
the most subscribed [ __ ] on youtubes
you better shut up I don't mean it I'm
not serious so please stop taking things
that I'm saying obviously as a joke
seriously I am I gonna have to stop
making jokes at all like I know most
people get it I know most people get it
and I just hate how people keep putting
these tabs on me which aren't true just
because and another thing is that a lot
of people seem to say he doesn't enjoy
it anymore he doesn't enjoy making
videos and which isn't true either I I
enjoy making videos more than I think I
ever have on YouTube because I'm
focusing more on action to making videos
than trying to please all my fans maybe
that's what I should be doing but I make
youtube for to have fun and if other
people enjoy it too
and that's great that's what I want to
do it should be free it should be fun it
should be amazing so it's way to people
still say oh he doesn't enjoy making
videos he just makes them to make us
happy but yes a little bit of course but
it's really not like that at all and I
make the videos I want to make and I get
a lot of people complaining in weird
ways like saying for example he just
fakes being scared he's not actually
scared and that's a comment on a happy
wheels video and it's like what what why
why did he say that
[ __ ] don't make sense but I guess my
point is if you if there's something
that you don't maybe like about me or my
channel or whatever um I appreciate it I
want to hear about it I want to hear
what you Brewers feel and I really do
listen to it but I need something better
I need something that says maybe I'll
good bye I really miss when you used to
play horror games maybe you could play
this game and give a recommendation
instead of saying play more are against
your [ __ ] it doesn't really help just
saying that so if you really do care and
you want to help then be more
constructive with it because I really do
listen to your bros and I do care about
what you say I know I always complain
I'm sorry but there's so many of you
bros who are just amazing and I see you
I read as many comments as I can on the
forums and the ones that doesn't make it
through the approval system ah and it
gives me strength it gives me power you
boys give me super powers so good bad
it's true if I complain that's because I
want it to be better so don't so don't
get me wrong I just want to say to all
of you
listening watching fat fapping don't
type right now
please I appreciate every single one of
you I don't take a single one of you for
granted
everyone is watching my videos and
appreciate it I appreciate you you are
the greatest
and don't forget it there's two comes
brofist for you as always brush share
your arm up